been tracking a number of major fires  haven't we in london and  the south east surrey specifically well  this refers to an update from surrey  fire brigades who have told us in the  past few minutes that as of at 6 40  tonight what had been declared a major  incident is no longer being considered  as such however it is still a wildfire  and we still ask you to avoid the area  so uh this is a  large blaze at this nature reserve in  surrey not far from that farnham  affecting at least eight hectares of  land a danger to people living nearby  from you can see their uh flames and  smoke taken by a viewer that people have  been told still to keep doors and  windows closed and pets inside but no  longer a major incident still though  say sorry fire brigade a wildfire